I my name is David Abrams I'm 15 years
old I live in Cape Town poke up in the
Cape Malay area mostly everyday you see
tourists coming down down the road
because of the color forces I want to
know the history of woke up and the
history of Cape Town I stay with my
father in cap ministry and my sister
loves day two and my two grandparents
and my cousin my uncle and four students
my sister she is very well-behaved
she's cute and sometimes she can be a
little naughty person like she will do
something to you that will irritate you
in the after she laughs about
I like going to school because I have a
few favorite subjects I like solving
equations solving for x different
geometry and trigonometry I'm afraid of
God because anything can happen to me at
any time you can just take me away from
Earth any time if you say your religious
place so so I am
psychedelic music keeps you put you in a
trance and it's best to doesn't a
psychedelic on an outdoor party and then
without a bunch of friends because the
manual you feel the vibe altogether
I go swim ask my friends if they would
like to hang out